[拍手]
若い方の後にこんなおっさんが出てきていますけれども同社中学校の入り口と申します
社会科を担当しています
教員生活21年を迎えました
10年前ぐらいから自分の授業がいまいちいけてないなというふうに思い始めて回転を
しようと思っています
そのきっかけは卒業生たちとのある会話の中です
卒業生に中学校のころの思い出わーっと聞くとほとんどの子たちがクラブや学園祭の
ことは言うんですけれども
授業のことは言ってくれない
井口の授業どうだったって聞いても同學系ってのいってさらっと流されてほとんどの
授業を忘れてしまっているということに
dqn としました
これでいいんだな
やっぱり記憶に残してほしいって思う
教師って子供たちの記憶に残る授業を本当にしてるやろうか
日々考えるべきだと思います
ではどんな授業をすれば子どもたちの記憶に残るかということで悶々としていたんです
けれども
し5年前あたりから
アクティブラーニングなんていうことがよく言われるようになりました
アクティブラーニングてすごいなぁと思う部分は確かにあります
学びの2いるはたようになったしバリエーションがたくさんたくさん増えてい
だから子供たち自身の中にも自分にあった勉強のスタイルはこうだとか
私はこれはちょっと苦手だなぁとか積極的に学びのスタイルについて
アピールするような子たちが出てきました
こうしたことを受けて僕自身も例えば
ポスターセッション行ったりあるいは発表をやったりして子どもたち同士がナビあっ
たり教え合う
いうようなことをやってみたんですね表情で喋りましたから
これは行って成功だなと思います
いくつかだけ紹介しようと思いますあまり時間がありませんので早口になるかも知れ
ませんか
例えばある男の子たちのグループが就職難ということをテーマに話し合います
発表したんですね
街中でて言って就活をしてなんか暗い顔してはる人をわざわざ見つけてきてあんた
どんな仕事をやろうと千大丈夫みたいにして中学生が言っていくわけです怖いもの知ら
ずで怖いですねほんとに中に女の子で深刻そうな顔してインタビューしたら1時間も
捕まっちゃったと言って言ってたんですけど
その子たちから聞いた内容で作ったのがこのビニールがさ
あーちょっとよく抜けてください
面白いんですよ
エントリーシートなんか送るけれども全部いらないと魚とされる書類選考で落ち
落とされて落ち込んで就活を嫌になるますますを借りにくくなる危機意識でどんどん
どんどん何社でも受けようとするとその会社に受かりたいという熱意が生まれなくなっ
ていく
だから会社側からもその情熱をか
感じられないということでまた面接で失敗する悪魔のサイクルダート界ってこれ回す
わけですよ
だから
こういうことをやられると線
飲んで中学の教師してるボクなんか太刀打ちできないわけですよ
同市や同やと子どもたちが盛り上がって結局僕の授業よりこれらの授業の方が覚えてる
っていうことになる
こんな風に教室の中で発表しただけじゃなくてさらに突き抜けた子たちが出てきました
例えばこの放置自転車をなくそうなんていうことを取り組んだ女の形
高槻商店街には1000台を超える放置自転車があって商店街の皆さんが困っていると
いうことを聞きつけたからなんとかしてその
放置自転車をなくそうという
取り組むをさせてくださいって言ってどんどんどんどんを仕掛けたんですね
ところが商店街の事務局の方々は
いやーちょっと勘弁してって言うという
ポスター貼らせて下さいだめ地らしく鳴らせて下さいだめ
音楽かけてアピールさせてもらって歌を歌わせてダメ
なぜかというと大人たちはこの工賃店者の大半はお客さんなんだと
だからお客さんが減るようなことはできないしどうしようって悩ましいんだ
中学生たちは自分が訴えていることは正しいと思ってますから
どうしたらいいんだろうって言って子どもと大人のバトルですが最初
でも3回4回とか良いながらあーでもないこーでもないと言ってるうちに
大人の方がだんだんだんだ子供の方に根負けしていくんですよ
そこでいつのまにか子どもと大人が対等にアイデアを出し合ってどうしたらいいアロ
ンなに行ったら中学生でもやれることだろーって言って協力し合って結局彼女たちの
発表はさらに工夫もされて
こんな発表なんです
実はあるニュース番組を真似して今日は放置自転車をなくそうと取り組んでいる中学生
を取材しました
では現地にいるなになりさんって言ってこの動画を流し
その動画の中で彼女たちは放置自転車をなくそうということをアピールする
メッセージをアーケードの中に流れる bgm の合間合間に自分たちの声で入れさせ
てもらうということをしたんです
商店街の人たちもそれやったらいいよって言って bgm が1曲途切れたら彼女たち
の声で長時間の駐輪はお読みくださいって穴をするな
しばらくの間これは続けられていて今現在どうかは分かりませんけれども
彼女たちはちょっとだけ自分たちが社会貢献できたと思っ
けれども放置自転車をほとんどなくならなかったってて笑って発表してました
だから彼女たちのムーブメントというのは成功したかと言われるとあまり効果がなかっ
たっていうことで終わるんですけれども自分たちの思いを受けて大人が変わってくれて
大人と一緒に一つのムーブメントができたという喜びがあって失敗を乗り越えながら
やっと達成できたことっていうことですごく喜んでたんです
こんなことができる中学生がいるんですよっても僕有頂天でしょ
彼女たちもそれから逆さを作ったあの子達も自分の授業の中で土曜日にも日曜日にも
集まってこんなことを作ってくれて
3回も昇天が入って交渉してそしてやり遂げてその上でしかも失敗あったてへって笑っ
て自分で i am ok って言えているそんなすごい子供達がいるんですって言っ
てこの発表をいろんな学校でさせて頂いて自分の手柄のように行ってました
けれども一方で実は
すごく大きな問題に直面し始めたんです
何かというと
井口の授業は嫌だ
授業に行きたくない
とうとう学校にも行きたくないって言い出す子たちが出たんです
なぜかというと僕はことあるごとにこういったことを発表してしまいましたので子ども
たちの中ではちゃんと
た
なんていうかな
プレゼンができないとダメしかも街中や出て行って自分を知らない人に喋りかけて
あるいはムーブメントもしなきゃいけないみたいなことを言われていくと僕にはでき
ない
私は一人でコツコツができるけどグループの中で意見を言うなんて無理
まして発表なんてって言って
そのことがプレッシャーになって学校に行き値振りを始めちゃって
保護者の方からのクレームの嵐でした
だからあ
やっちまったな
どうしたらこの僕の授業への拒否反応や拒絶を乗り越えることができるだろうか
次の大きな問題に直面してしまいます
僕自身が個性そういった学びのスタイルが多様になったと先ほど言ったにもかかわらず
そうした子どもたちの個性を無視して発表だけが大事
moon 面と何かしなきゃいけないみたいなことだけを言ってしまってたんだと思う
んですね
これが井口の暴力だったんだろうと思います
それに耐えかねた子供たちがトート事業に対する拒否拒絶をしちゃうん
それに直面したときどうしようかと本気で悩みます答えは今でも見つかっていませんが
手がかりになるような風景には時々あります
例えばこの
風景僕のお気に入りの写真の一つです
僕が担任をしていた中学3年生の子達
5月ごろに学園祭の出し物を決めようっていうことで昼休みに初なって話し合いをして
いたんです
食堂に行って食べる子たちあるいはボール遊びをしたい子達もいただろうに
みんなでこうやって机阿室を全部退けてしまって車がうっていうか a
理系に座ってワイワイガヤガヤと喋ってたんです
何やってんだろうと思って覗きに行った時にこの光景を見た時
慌ててカメラを取りに行って写真に収めていた
ニヤニヤと笑いながらこの写真にで仕事が入って見てたんです
その時あることに気がつきましたん
この
円形に座っている
グループの中にはいなかった外側にいた子達です
よく見るとこの子たちこそが僕の授業では拒否反応を示してた子たちだ
ん
発表しにくい誰かと
なんていうのかな a
フレンドリーのシャベルとか
コミュニケーションをとるっていうのがちょっと苦手
で教室では円形にこうやって座ってあーだこーだとどんな出しもするって言って喋っ
てるんですけれどもその場の中に入ることを拒否をしているわけではないんです
僕の授業に対する拒絶なんかとは比べ物にならない緩やかな拒否反応できず進んでるん
ですよね
でなんとなくこのワイワイガヤガヤを遠目で見てなんとなく一体化
なんとなく金親近感を持つ円の中に座っている子たちも入ってポン様と強制しないん
ですね
そこでチキっと聞いてくれているだろうと言います
この子たちは結局学園祭では裏方の音響係であるとか大道具係をしてプラス2では大
成功を収めました
この拒否ではない柔らかな一体化緩やかな一体化
これがなぜ授業の中でうまくできないんだろうか
こうした一体感を授業の中で再現してみたい
居心地がいいこと居場所があること
安心できることこれが何故か教室の授業のときにうまくできなかった
アクティブラーニングと言われてミーティングだあるいは
プレゼンテーションだと言われたときにコミュニケーション能力がまだまだ未熟だ買っ
たりあるいは個性として他社と誰かと何かをするよりはどちらかというと哲学的に自分
の思考の中でしっかり入っていきたいみたいな子たちにとってはオープンマインドと
いうのはものすごく居心地が悪いんですよね
皆さんの中にもスタバでだと落ち着かないという人もいるかもしれません
僕だったらある意味ではマイル少し雑音があっても自分の世界に入れるんですけれども
苦手な子っていうのはやっぱり周りを囲ってあげた方が落ち着くんです
ちょっと動きが大きい公ってあのにビーズクッションと言われるクッションがあると
そこにスポット治るとコードが落ち着いたりほっこりするんですね
そういったものが授業の教室の中になぜないんだろう
我々は従来の講義形式に戻していっ
今までこういった個性の違いとかいうのも全部棚上げにしてきた時代に戻ることはでき
ないと思います
ではどういうことが望まれるべきアクティブラーニングは開け開けと言います
けれども僕はあえてそこにと白と白と言いたいんです
開くと同時に少しだけ閉じた空間を
教室の授業の中に作ってあげないとダメなんだ
円もだ作って座って喋っているそういうグループをちょっとだけ離れた位置から緩やか
に見守る
そういう空間を事業の中で作ってあげたい
これはどうしたらいいか建築の問題として考えるべきなよ
2010年に僕は中学校を移転させたグループだったんですけれどもその建築を考える
ときにもいろいろ考えましたが
お金がかかっちゃうから建築の問題としてこれに取り組むというのは相当難しいんです
ではカムやったらいいか
家具だと模様替えとかで雰囲気を変えることができますが非常に小さい
もうちょっと何かないかなで考えている時に学校建築の牽引のある建築家の先生から次
のようなことをアドバイスもらいました
最近棟建築というものと数というものの長所を合わせた
archi funny チャーと言われるような考え方ができてるんだよ
僕はもうすぐにこれに飛びつきましたでその建築家の先生にお願いをしてどっか
会社紹介してもらえませんかぜひこの archi ファンチャーを中学生と一緒に
作りたいって思ったんです
中学生と企業そして建築家と一緒にコラボしながら学びのための空間として何が作れる
か今それに取りかかり
2020年にアクティブラーニングの小中学校に導入されるのに合わせて
archi ふぁにーちゃんを販売できるペースでやっていきたいと動きつつ
ありません
あまりとたくさんのことはちょっと企業秘密なので言えないんですけれど
今現在同社中学校はこのような一人分の机と椅子を整然と並べて黒板に向かっています
一般的な教室とよく似たものです
けれどもこういう教室で例えば僕は事業で考えなさいって言った瞬間に子どもたちは
黙り込むんです
僕が考えなさいと言われたら隣の人にお前どう思うって聞きたくなるんです
つまり考える=喋るなんですよこの場合
中には考えるとになると自分で自分の世界にぐっと没頭できる子たちもいます
そういった考え方のスタイル自体もバラバラなので
この教室のある方っていうのは実は教える側にとってのみ有効な教室なんですね
そこを現在は廊下側だけはこれぐらいかバッグを開けるようにしたんですけれども開く
方向にはどんどんどんどん進みました
でも一人分の机と椅子があるもんやから完全にも心を開かない
だから緊張感ばかりが教室の中に誰だよっ
では教室ではないところにこうやってリビングスペースみたいなものを作りました
畳を置いてちょっとぐらいは子どもたちが癒されるかなと期待した
ところが子どもたちにとっては授業の時間こそが緊張が高まっているので
教室の中にこれがほしいっていうこと
僕らは教室は勉強のところりりんはリビングって言って負けちゃう
でもそうじゃなかったんです子供達が居場所がないって感じるのは授業中なんです
だから事業の空間にこそ落ち着くようなリビングスペースが欲しいと言い出しています
それを archi ファニチャを作っ使って教室自体をアレンジしていくん
そういった開くと閉じるを同時に成立させるような学校空間を作りたいという思っ
でもこんなね抽象的なことばっかり言うててどんなもんなんだろう
実は僕もそれはよくわかっていますそこが中学生の醍醐味で彼らは発想豊かにこうやっ
たらいいん違う
例えばハンモックがあるといいよねーよとか
あるいは仲の良いお友達と2人で座れるベンチがあったらいいよな
映画館のあのカップル席みたいな感じで言ってるような子達までいました
ん
寝そべって授業を受けたいああなるほどなそんなこと全部を考えられるんだろうか思い
ながら
でもちょっとチャレンジ
今僕が一つだけを持っているのはこのアルネヤコブセンという人のエッグ地や
これ最高のデザインだと僕は思っています
背もたれの部分が緩やかなカーブで面白い形をしています
これを見3個あるいは4つ5つと円形に並べるとこのような形になって
そもそもはホテルのロビーに置く椅子としてデザインされたんです
開かれた空間ですけれどもこれに座って数名で円形を作るとこの背もたれの部分の
カーブが緩やかに周りの人の視線を遮ってくれるんですその結果
数人の人たちで閉じた空間をオープンスペースの中にいくつもいくつも作れるような
椅子なんですよね
このアルネヤコブセンが提唱した開くと同時に閉じるというようなことを成立させる
デザイン
これを学校空間のしかも授業の場所に作ってみた
開きながら閉じるそれを中学生と一緒に作ってみた
そうして新たな価値や新たな学校のスタイルというのを発信できる新しい
インフラとしての学校あえて言えばカルチャーインフラとしての学校を中学生と一緒に
作っていきたいというのが今の僕の試みでできれば2020年にまたこうした部隊が
あれば
その商品を持ってこの場でお話しできたらなぁと思っています
ありがとうございました
[拍手]